[Music]
ever since I was a kid my hair was
everything I had to be fixed only then
was I perfect you might go to girl good
job tonight it's gonna be the happiest
moment of my life
what do you get the perfect woman meet
Lola
I was expecting a ring you said I'm
perfect 24/7 perfection you never let
your hair down you don't want you on the
account you can sponsor like six kids
with them money you spend it for hair
excuse me eyeball shots of my daughter
she knows better Wow just be yourself
who would that be the anal compulsive
miss perfect cut or the not fun never
spontaneous weave well personally I
really like to leave I've worked so hard
to be perfect and it still wasn't enough
[Music]
you think this is just something you did
okay I think you've been building up to
[Music]
you gotta own it girl yes
where you going to do
brother is born as a woman hoes you real
my dad won't let me perm my hair you
don't need to do that this craziness has
got to stop that's right that's right
my hair was like a second job now I'm
forced to focus on myself
I wonder who I'll be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]